Цим німецьким симфонічним оркестром у місті Веймар диригує українець,
ім’я якого відоме на весь світ. За допомогою своєї диригентської палички
він не лише підкорив вершини класичної музики, але й відкриває світові нову Україну.
Кирило Карабиць у вересні цього року очолив найстаріший оркестр Німеччини,
якому виповнилося 525 років. Робота у Веймарі, в якому творив Бах
та ставив «Фауста» Гете – натхнення та виклик для українського диригента.
Втім, довіру вибагливих німецьких музикантів українець завоював одразу.
Це прекрасно, що пан Карабиць з нами. Ми вже зіграли разом кілька проектів
і він завжди розкриває серце, коли стоїть на сцені.
39-річний Кирило Карабиць схильний до музичних експериментів.
В репертуар німецького оркестру він привносить східноєвропейські нотки.
Цього вечора він поєднує вірменську музику з Бетховеном. Українського "Щедрика" тут вже опанували.
На радянських композиторах закінчується фактично культурна карта Європи...
І я вибрав для себе саме от такий шлях – не тільки грати відому музику, а грати й невідому.
Ну, в тому числі й українську музику. Але не відразу, а поступово.
Кирило переконаний: саме завдяки митцям світ дізнається,
що таке Україна та чим вона відрізняється від Росії.
Якщо ми самі розуміємо, хто ми такі, то легше розказувати і німцям,
і іншим європейцям, якщо ми самі розуміємо це.
Саме різницю між Україною та Росією, а не ворожість - демонструє світові диригент.
І сподівається, що культура зможе колись відновити цивілізовані
відносини між країнами, які зруйнувала політика.
Тим часом диригент скріплює дружні відносини України та Німеччини.
Попри численні проекти в Україні, Кирило Карабиць розмірковує, чи не оселитися остаточно у Веймарі.
Поки що він підписав контракт на 3 роки.
Тим більше на Батьківщину видатного на весь світ диригента не кличуть.
Якщо мене запросить якийсь оркестр, тоді я буду думати. Німецький оркестр мене запросив.
Незважаючи на багаторічний досвід диригування та найпрестижніші премії світу
Кирило Карабиць досі хвилюється перед виступом.
Зокрема, перед німцями, які мають чи не найглибші в світі традиції класичної музики.
Утім, схоже, глядачі його музику відчувають.
Я уявив собі війну в Алеппо або деінде з літаками, з ракетами, з людьми, які скорблять.
Це абсолютно новий стиль музики, який надихає.
Мені нагадало це пустелю, повний місяць і східні мотиви.